[Musica]
Io sono un poeta
sono Figuratevi un poeta professionista
sono un poeta professionista vivente
vivente la parola più importante io sono
molto felice di essere vivo Sono felice
che voi siete qui vivi
ma soprattutto quando ha iniziato a
scrivere tanti anni fa un pensiero che
mi assillava era questo dicevo se le
cose che scrivo andando bene piaceranno
mi piacerebbe goderne da vivo Cioè non
rientra in quella categoria di poeti di
artisti di musicisti di pittori punto
muoiono e poi vengono valutati vengono
apprezzati Amati No da postumi una cosa
di cattivo gusto Pensavo mi piacerebbe
andare avanti da vivo con la mia poesia
No non sono sempre stato un poeta
professionista Chiaramente come non sono
sempre stato
un sex symbol
avete riso perché credete che sia una
battuta non lo è Io a un certo punto
della mia vita sono diventate un sex
symbol Ma la cosa strana che lo sono
diventate in età matura Cioè non da
giovane uno pensa che sex simbolo lo
dimenti da giovane ed è una bella
notizia quella che vi sto dando perché
potete riuscirci anche voi magari voi
avete pensato sperato mi piacerebbe
essere un sex symbol Ma ormai ho 30 35
40 45 anni non ce la posso più fare no
io sono qui a dimostrare che si può
diventare sexy single anche in età
matura e tra l'altro Te la godi di più
perché sei più saggio più saggio non
sono Chiaramente sempre stato un sexy
simbolo Anzi anzi ve l'ho detto Ci sono
arrivato abbastanza tardi e invece una
gran parte della mia vita una prima
lunga parte della mia vita io l'ho
vissuta con delle difficoltà nei
confronti degli altri esseri umani
in generale in particolare con le
ragazze con le donne intorno a me
succedevano cose vedevo non vi sto solo
parlando
dell'adolescenza vi sto parlando anche
della posta adolescenza della post posta
delle Scienze anche della Scienza potrei
andare avanti così per 5 minuti intorno
a me succedevano cose no i miei amici i
miei conoscenti iniziavano le loro
esperienze io i primi baci
per i fidanzamenti poi sempre di più
sempre di più io mi sentivo fuori scala
Mi sentivo fuori media perché sapete ci
sono delle medie anche delle statistiche
anche su questi passi importanti del
dell'esperienza umana il in Italia ad
esempio il primo bacio
la statistica è 11 13 anni di media
alle medie peraltro quindi è perfetto il
primo rapporto sessuale completo
17 anni se io vi dicessi quando ha dato
il primo bacio voi non ci credevo est se
io vi dicessi quando ho fatto per la
prima volta all'amore Vi giuro non ci
crederai e io comunque non ve lo dico
però comunque sia non è a mio agio se ne
sto parlando con il sorriso ma ho
passato dei brutti periodi di brutti
momenti Anche perché nessuno mi diceva
una cosa importantissima che poi ho
scoperto che non ero strano non ero
diverso non ero malato Semplicemente
avevo dei tempi diversi rispetto alla
massa Questo può succedere in questa
società dove tutti fanno una cosa tutti
insieme spesso succede questo tu ti
senti
in dovere senti in dovere invece ognuno
di noi ha dei tempi molto personali ai
tempi però nessuno me l'ha detto e
quindi non me la sono vissuta bene cos'è
che mi è venuto in aiuto vi chiederete
mi è venuta in aiuto la poesia torniamo
alla poesia ho iniziato a scrivere
tantissime poesie d'amore in un momento
in cui l'amore non ci capivo un granché
lo ha fatto proprio per cercare di
capirci di più ho scritto da quei tempi
all'altro ieri ho scritto una quantità
spaventosa di poesie d'amore che se le
metto tutti insieme solo le poesie
d'amore ne viene quattro chili e mezzo
che è tanto vi assicuro
ho scritto tante poesie d'amore e questo
scrivere di una cosa che non capivo ma
che cercavo di capire che cercavo di
scoprire Mi è servito Adesso vi leggerò
qualcuna di queste poesie no Ho qui dei
libri
poesie scritte anche molto molto tempo
fa
la prima cosa che vi voglio leggere
parla proprio della difficoltà di
comunicazione in questo caso tra un uomo
e una donna e non è propriamente una
poesia È un dialogo scritto anche molti
molti dialoghi
è un dialogo bucolico Tra l'altro tema
bucolico o oltre che oltre che al fatto
delle difficoltà di comunicazione parla
quindi di natura di natura si capisce
dal titolo Il titolo è Ti piacerebbe
andare amore
Scusate è un gioco di parole stupide Io
odio i giochi di parole ma era fine anni
90 quindi Figuratevi inizia l'uomo poi
c'è la donna fa così Ab Ab faccio tutti
e due io perché sono da solo
Ti piacerebbe andare amore con me
pungendoci Ditti ti piacerebbe
via castagne e funghi e ortiche Ma tu lo
sai che si mangia dalle ortiche
pungendoci di ti piacerebbe
no
Mi disse non ho proprio non mi
piacerebbe imperditi chiesi non ho
proprio non mi piacerebbe andarci con te
stai parlando a me sì sì A te non ti
piaccio proprio che non mi interessa ma
le more sì tu no
le castagne tu no Sì le castagne Le
ottiche Le ottiche anche no ma comunque
non con te
a pesca no a caccia no
sparare ai topi alla discarica
mi trovi basso
No è che non ti cerco
quindi non ti trovo hai un innamorato in
altre lande sono singola ti piace
baciare le ragazze non mi piace baciare
i ragazzi Scusa ma allora cosa ci fai
dentro la mia poesia È un tuo problema
passavo di qui mi ci hai messo dentro tu
Scusami sono sbagliato Non ti
preoccupare Vabbè buona passeggiata
Grazie un cinema Fatti furbo Ok ciao
ciao
Grazie
ringrazio
vi ringrazio
Adesso vi leggo invece una poesia
d'amore però non vi leggo una poesia
d'amore che parla di quel momento
bellissimo che tutti noi tutti voi spero
abbiate almeno una volta vissuto c'è
l'inizio l'inizio
del rapporto della storia è uno due
giorni settimane mesi questo inizio
qui che parlo della fine della fine
della storia perché purtroppo le storie
d'amore tendono a finire Lo sapete e
questa è una poesia che quindi rientra
nella categoria delle poesie di fine
rapporto le pfeo Ok su una strada lo so
suona strano ne ho scritte tante di quei
quattro chili e mezzo di poesie che ho
scritto due chili sono di PFM perché io
abbia avuto tanti rapporti quindi tanti
fini rapporti ma ogni volta che c'è un
fine rapporto Io diciamo mi ispiro
parecchio questa è una classica pfeo e
si intitola tutto sbagliato
e fu così
che ci trovammo nel posto sbagliato al
momento giusto O forse al posto giusto
al momento sbagliato con tutta
probabilità era tutto sbagliato il posto
ed il momento erano sbagliati gli alberi
e le strade e ho sbagliato il cielo ed
il cemento e sbagliata tu e ho sbagliato
io sbagliamo il primo bacio e l'ultimo
il primo appuntamento il primo orgasmo
fu sbagliato e fu sbagliato il primo
fu sbagliato a dirti t'amo fu
sbagliato dirti Ti odio in realtà ti
odio non te lo dissi mai lo pensai
sbagliando però sbagliò la luna adesso
la piena quella notte Ha illuminato il
viso sbagliando i tuoi occhi ad essere
belli impianto sbagliano gli abbracci
quelli non dati quelli dati quelli non
chiesti quelli sperati e fu così
che ci perdemmo il sole sorse ad ovest
abbaiarono i cavalli i tassisti romani
offrirono un giro gratis a tutti
Grazie sì
i tassisti romani
che voglio incontrarti un poeta vivente
che riesce a mettere i tassisti romani
dentro una poesia d'amore io ci sono
riuscito quando una storia finisce ora
la naturale conseguenza è che uno abbia
una ex fidanzata o un ex fidanzato che
gira per il mondo libero sono liberi di
farlo È incredibile
Voi direte Ma tra di voi ci sono degli
ex fidanzati delle ex fidanzate e siete
qui e potete farlo ho proprio fatto uno
studio a livello legale e anche
costituzionale si può fare però a me
ogni tanto ha dato fastidio questa cosa
c'ho scritto una poesia tanti anni fa
una poesia che tra l'altro anche ha a
che fare con l'astrofisica ok Quindi se
c'è qualche astrofisico in sala ne godrà
doppiamente Infatti si intitola
Supernova e fa così
l'ex fidanzata
rimangono belle da farti del male quando
le vedi da farti del male da farti
sognare rimango più ex fidanzate tu hai
più ex fidanzate tu incontri
più belle di prima più belle non puoi
farci nulla le incontro alle feste Sui
treni nei campi se vai a far vendemmia
le incontri le inconte tra l'uva un
fazzoletto che tiene i capelli
raccolgono i grappoli se fai il muratore
non si affacciano dalla finestra
sorridono e trovi dovunque su spiagge
nei boschi in giardino fuggire non serve
l'ex fidanzata era incontri son belle
sono i capelli biondi sono più biondi di
prima se hanno gli occhi azzurri sono
più occhi di Allora se hanno un corpo
Beh hanno un corpo che vorresti farci le
cose sapete le cose
le cose se tu poi vai in guerra vieni
quasi sicuramente ferito dai nazisti Poi
finisci in ospedale e l'infermiera
francese che ti cura e lei
la tua ex fidanzata se tu cammini di
notte Dio bono nella notte tu vedi cioè
una bici sulla bici c'è un sellino sul
sellino c'è un culo il culo di lei la
tua ex fidanzata che sfreccia di notte
l'ex fidanzata rimangono belle ma l'ex
fidanzate poi si rifidanzano e ti
parlano come se tu fossi lì davanti a
loro come se tu fossi una persona come
se tu fossi loro ti parlano e non
capiscono che tu non sei più tu stai
viaggiando nello spazio immenso dove
muoiono e dove nascono le stelle dove Il
silenzio è tuo amico e la tua prossima
donna sarà una Supernova con i capelli
rossi e un sacco di voglia di fare
all'amore
l'ex fidanzato
Adesso vi leggo una poesia d'amore
invece felice una poesia d'amore in cui
il poeta il poeta esprime tutta l'amore
che può nei confronti della persona
amata si intitola ma meno male che ti
amo
e fa così
stamattina
mi sono svegliato e la prima cosa che ho
pensato Anzi la seconda La prima è stata
Ora devo proprio aprire gli occhi la
seconda è stata pensa tu un mondo come
questo identico a questo sputato con
tutte le sue bordura e le sue bellezze
il suo regno animale vegetale e minerale
con tutto il suo cielo il suo sole le
sue nuvole le sue città i suoi bambini
il suo vento l'inchiostro i gatti le
lacrime i libri le risate con tutte le
sue guerre La stupidità agli dei palati
i mari di ignoranza le montagne di
tristezza i laghi di paura i deserti di
pazzia i grattacieli di solitudine gli
ammezzati di stupidità pensa tu un mondo
come questo identico sputato dove però
io non ti amavo magari manco ti sapevo
Ecco stamattina dopo che mi mi sono
svegliato dopo che ho aperto gli occhi
ho pensato ma meno male che ti amo e ti
confesso ho detto pure ad alta voce lo
sussurrato nella solitudine della mia
stanza poi lo so a qualcuno potrebbe
sembrare cosa di poco conto beh
non lo è
molto bella
lo ammetto
era molto romantica questa questo sulla
scala Catalano è un 9.7 che il record
europeo di romanticismo per una poesia
questa che vi leggo adesso invece non è
una poesia romantica e di nuovo una
poesia di fine rapporto la leggo
solamente per un motivo un mezzo Perché
le voglio bene L'ho scritto tanto tempo
fa è un po' la madre di tutte le pfei
almeno di quelle che ho scritto io ci
mancherebbe ma soprattutto è una poesia
breve e utile utile nella pratica cioè
io vela regalo in un certo senso potete
usarla Se volete lasciare qualcuno
funziona la potete proprio e anche
imparare a memoria perché è molto breve
la potete dire dire così a voce io vi
consiglio di fare così con il dito
sinistro con l'abbraccio dito e dire tu
tu perché ho sentito la tu così non
dovete solo sputargli in faccia
tu se tu fossi un puffo
tu saraissi il Fuffo stronzo
Se tu fossi un Barbapapà
tu saresti barba merda
Se tu fossi un supereroe tu se avessi la
donna muco
Se tu fossi un Pokémon
Qualsiasi tanto fanno schifo uguale
Ma poi a conti fatti e concludo tu sei
tu e solamente tu gli appenni lasciamoli
ai poeti e alle poetesse da premio
letterario
Se tu fossi il sole Cazzo che freddo
eh molto dura
Grazie amici questa dura
Siccome il tema del di questa giornata
l'amore verso il prossimo Insomma è che
non potevo finire con una roba del
genere
e vi leggo invece una poesia che parla
della Speranza davvero la speranza parla
di una cosa importante parla
del fatto che quando le cose si fanno
difficili Ecco una cosa importantissima
è stata insieme stai vicini un po' Come
si va facendo oggi Vale per due persone
ma vale anche per tante persone
Il titolo è teniamoci stretti che c'è
vento forte una metafora meteo ma io
parlo anche si parla non solo di vento
in questo caso chiaramente fa così
teniamoci strette che c'è vento forte
che ci porta via
teniamoci stretti facciamoci stretti
bellezza mia
abbracciamoci con i bracci
agganghiamoci con le gambe
addentiamoci annodiamo i nostri capelli
e i nostri capelli incastriamoci le dita
dei piedi Diamoci le mani guardiamoci
senza mai dimenticarci di guardarci
Dentro gli occhi c'è un vento così forte
che ci porta via
teniamoci stretti che c'è vento forte
ancoriamoci l'una l'altro l'altro
all'una finché non calma e se non calma
perché potrebbe non calmare Bada
potrebbe se Ci molliamo saremo
scaraventati via lontano sarà poi
difficile trovarci forse impossibile
dimenticaremo le nostre voci le nostre
facce dimenticheremo ciò che ci piaceva
dirci e farci
teniamoci stretti che c'è vento forte
bellezza mia Io ti tengo strette mia
unica bellezza che tu mi tieni
ed io sia maledetto sia maledetto io non
Dio se mollo questa presa di salvezza
[Risate]